this might look like a hobby or
entertainment to many but eSport is
taking off globally it's about to become
a billion-dollar industry here in
Shanghai site of the International or ti
the annual championship for online game
dota 2 the prizes for winners totaling
33 million dollars breaking the previous
record set last month but as eSport
grows so are health concerns for these
young players many are teenagers like
Kyle gears Dorf a 16 year old American
who last month picked up three million
dollars for coming first in the
fortnight world cup the highest ever
individual win for an eSport event the
concerns are for player's physical
health with the hours and hours of
sitting and repetitive motion and also
mental given the high stress of big
money on the line not to mention
millions of people watching each and
every move burnout and anxiety are an
increasing issue underage eSport betting
is also a concern a recent UK study
estimates that globally 45% of tweets
about eSport betting reaches young
people below the legal minimum age EDG
is one of the leading eSport companies
in China it operates in a similar way to
professional athletic clubs the players
live and train on site once says going
pro is not for everyone it depends on
what your interest and what you are good
at if you have the talent and confidence
about yourself you can choose eSports
otherwise you should spend more time
studying EDG starts recruiting players
at 16 and they reach their prime between
19 and 21 the two main factors are
choosing good esports players one is
talent the second is hot training when
we Scout these kids with good talent
will provide them good training eSport
fans are not only watching live
streaming thousands pack the competition
for dota 2 paying hundreds of dollars
for tickets some in the China eSport
industry see competitions growing beyond
just being housed in large arenas that
are normally used for big athletic
events like this one here in Shanghai
but that eventually the
become part of international athletic
games no to the whale is leading away I
am very confident that eSports who
become formal play in Asian Games or
even the Olympics this is the trend and
this trend is unstoppable with the
potential of eSport elevating beyond big
money becoming a game of national pride
through teams representing their country
training and strategy will become even
more secretive and intense Scott Hodler
al-jazeera
Shanghai